[Music]
way I look forward to the
competitiveness the competition over
Bron James of the Cavaliers and Dwayne
Wade of the Miami Heat the two young
superstars
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
back and forth one guy against the other
in the run and with these two guys
anything you can do
we just want to make the most of it we
want to have fun with them but you know
I have to work down we can always just
talk about a lot of fun times that you
have on the court and things that we did
to make a mark in Italy
[Applause]
[Music]
six
wave throws the perfect
[Applause]
[Music]
LeBron's Larvik the way
[Music]
[Applause]
wait my chain
imitating fast blanket basketball was
dewayne in the
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he knew he was getting it back to the
law the best basketball
- wait any fetishes
[Music]
related to change
[Applause]
to the basket
spectacular
[Applause]
foot level that these two guys
[Applause]
see just his beautiful basketball
where's the price of admission
[Applause]
changed all sit down
[Applause]
NBA champions
[Music]
torence with a choreographed Hampshire
pretty good tonight
the shoot drives of James
again
[Applause]
[Applause]
last time face each other
but what was not you know the same for
my brother
looking forward to the challenge once
again man